So it's
July 18th,
Tuesday,
2017,
and I've been working for the last few
days on the eighth lecture in my series,
the psychological significance of the
biblical stories and I'm planning to
talk about the abrahamic stories that
immediately follow the stories of Noah
and the Tower of Babel.
I'm not as familiar with abrahamic
stories as I am with the stories,
the earlier stories in genesis say from
the beginning of the Bible through the
stories of Noah and the Tower of Babel.
And I'm not as familiar with abrahamic
stories as I am with the stories of
Moses that begin with exodus and
continuing to succeeding chapters.
So I've had to do a lot of reading and a
lot of thinking and,
and some conversing as well.
And as part of that process,
I spoke once again with Jonathan Patio,
uh,
a carver of stone icons and an Orthodox
Christian and student of religion.
And also this time,
who I did a video with a while back,
you might remember called the
metaphysics of pepe,
where we discussed the psychology of the
stranger and also some of the stories,
abrahamic stories involving lot in Sodom
and Gomorrah,
and I also had the opportunity to meet
his brother Matthew Palio,
who's been working on a book on the
Bible for the last three and a half
years.
And so we spent 90 minutes talking about
the abrahamic stories and the conceptual
background that's necessary to
understand them.
And that's what I want to show you today
after this introduction.
So I hope it's useful.
So I'm going to introduce both of you.
So Jonathan is a carver of icons and
I've spoken with Jonathan a number of
times already and he now has his own
youtube channel as well,
where he discusses issues that are
similar to the ones that we're going to
discuss today.
In Matthew is his brother who I haven't
met before in Matthew,
has been working on a book for the last.
How long?
Two and a half years.
Three and a half years.
And do you want to tell everyone very
briefly about the book?
Well,
it's a book about symbolism,
but it's basically,
I'm trying to rediscover the world view
that was present in the time of the
Bible or at least actually not that long
ago because modern,
modern interpretations of reality,
materialists interpretations of reality
aren't that old,
right?
The world view that was there when
traditional societies were still there.
Um,
and so I'm trying to rediscover that
worldview and a,
basically there are basic patterns,
heaven and earth time and space,
things like things like that.
Uh,
so it's like a,
a cosmology that's been completely lost
as far as I'm concerned.
Some people have glimpses of it,
I think a lot of people do,
but it's very general patterns that we
have to re re understand.
So we can understand the Bible,
for example,
in other,
other storage.
They get interested
in this.
Like what is it that compelled you to do
this?
Oh,
I don't know where to start.
I mean,
my whole life has been about that.
So,
uh,
I mean,
you read the Bible,
you can take it literally,
you can take it figuratively or you can
take it both ways.
And I'm trying to take it both ways.
I'm trying to get rid of it,
the economy,
the dichotomy of symbolism and factual
description.
I think there is no such dichotomy.
If you understand what the words mean.
If you have the right perspective,
there's no more metaphors in the Bible.
There are no okay.
But it takes a while to get there
because you have to adopt a completely
different perspective than,
than the materialistic when obviously
you got to be a materialist and,
and a Christian or we can be a religious
and a materialist.
That's what I think.
Okay.
And one of the things we're hoping is
that,
you know,
we've been getting.
I've been getting a lot of questions and
I know you probably Jordan,
me getting a lot of questions about this
question of metaphor and a lot of people
have been asking me how do we reconcile,
how do I reconcile metaphors with what's
in the Bible?
How do I reconcile these metaphors with
how I'm supposed to live in the world
and I think that would,
matthew has been with his writing and
what I've been,
I've been reading it,
I'm reading it right now,
is that he,
he's really able to answer that question
in a way that I think will be one of the
most satisfying answers that we've seen
in in awhile.
So we're pretty excited to see how are
we going to get that out
to people.
So let me start by telling you what I've
been thinking about just briefly and
then you guys can comment and I'd like
you to do most of the talking if we can
manage that.
Although I'm so damn talkative,
it's hard to imagine that'll happen,
but.
So I've been reading this book called
the disappearance of God and I've been
using it as a.
it's a body guy named Richard Friedman
and it was published I think in 2005.
I think that's right.
It might have been earlier than that,
but he makes a couple of interesting
points about the all the braiding in the
old testament and and they're parallel
points and so the first is that the
closer you are to the beginning of the
Bible,
the more God is present and and as you
progress towards the end of the Old
Testament,
God sort of vanishes in stages until he
only manifests himself if at all,
in prophetic visions.
And at the same time the parallel
development is that the stories of
individual human beings become more and
more well developed.
So it's like as the idea of the
individual personality emerges or the
fact of the individual personality
emerges.
The the presence of God as a,
as a detectable entity like an external
entity even seems to decline
proportionately.
And so I'm trying to puzzle that out in
a variety of different ways.
Partly neurologically because there's
some evidence that the domain of
experience that you might associated
with my associate with the divine is a
consequence of suppressed lemons.
Left Hemisphere function and augmented
right hemisphere function.
And then I'm trying to also consider
that in relationship to the effect of
chemicals like silicide been,
which obviously can produce powerful
mystical experiences,
so experiences of consciousness that are
really have a different type than normal
waking ego consciousness,
and I've also been reading humans mostly
commentaries about humans read book and
his attempts to use active imagination
as a as a means to explore the contents
of different forms of consciousness,
which is something that modern people
just really never do.
Although he did it for years and and the
consequence of that was the red book,
also the black books,
which hasn't been published yet,
but the red book,
which was a,
which was I think published two or three
years ago.
That was a collection of visionary
experiences in his.
His continuing discussions with figures
of his imagination,
which he regarded as the most important
work he did in his life.
So,
so what's,
what does that all boil down to?
It's.
It's definitely possible for people to
have non can have to have experiences
outside the domain of their normal
consciousness that produced the
intimation of the divine.
That seems to be factually indisputable.
Those were not exactly sure how those
experiences manifested themselves in the
periods of time that are associated with
the early biblical stories.
Yeah,
the BIP,
the Bible talks about those sorts of
experiences very forthrightly in the
earliest abrahamic stories and also in
the story of Noah and obviously an Adam
and eve and all of that.
God is very present and then he
disappears over time and one of the
things that that I'm the guy who wrote
the disappearance of God Friedman.
One of the things he pointed out was
that the fact of the disappearance of
God in the Old Testament,
the fact that that's a.
that's,
that's a continual,
like it has narrative continuity.
That fact,
he already remarked on both those things
because of course the books were written
by different people and then they were
aggregated,
but out of that came to elements of
narrative continuity and one was the
gradual disappearance of God and the
other was the gradual rise of the
increasingly well-defined and powerful
individual.
So anyways,
associated with that is the idea that as
God withdraws,
he also starts to manifest himself more
through the idea of a covenant and that
the Covenant is something that's
established with an individual all
obviously also with the nation in the
case of Israel,
but it's mediated through individuals.
And so,
well,
that's a brief wander through the sort
of cloud of associations that make up my
thinking about the topic at the moment.
So,
well,
what you described sounds a lot like
what would you see in the Bible?
I'm not so sure about the god is more
distant part in,
further on and goes,
um,
from what I understand,
there are two kinds of consciousness in
the Bible.
One of them is it's called inhabiting
the land.
That's when reality fits the fact,
the theory.
Okay?
So the principal and the fact that
grief,
so their loss and people follow the laws
or there's an idea and reality fits with
that idea.
So that's called inhabiting the land.
So it,
it,
it's familiar space.
Okay.
So when you live in that space,
things make sense because your ideas
match what's happening,
right?
And then you can fall away from that.
That's the covenant.
A covenant is an agreement between
theory and practice.
That's what a covenant is in the Bible.
I'm so God gives laws and the people
have to agree to follow the law
basically.
So the law is,
is,
is an identity.
It's not just like you do this,
you do that.
It's,
it's,
it expresses God's identity in practice.
So when the facts match that identity,
that's like a soul and a body that are,
uh,
that a great.
Okay?
So when you fall away from that,
you fall into exile.
That's the other mode and it looks like,
um,
that's what you were talking about
before.
I'm not so sure until you've talked
about a coconut,
but,
um,
that's when the meaning and the fact
that do not know.
Touch.
Okay.
So,
so let me,
let me ask you a couple of questions
about that.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I've been describing the cosmology in
the Bible as mappable onto the domains
of order and chaos.
And I actually think the best way to
define the order,
his order is the place you are when what
you're doing matches what's happening.
It's very,
very,
very similar to the idea that you just
expressed.
And then that's exactly it.
Okay.
And yeah,
that's a state.
There's a state of harmony between
preconception and actuality.
And that's also,
I think the circumstance under which
people's emotions remain regulated.
And I thought about that neurologically
to.
I think that what happens is that under
those conditions,
your left hemisphere stays in charge and
there's some evidence for that kind of
thing too.
Especially from the writings of this
neurologist.
I think he's a neurologist.
His name is Ramachandra and he's quite a
famous brain scientist and he's an
another,
another neuropsychologist named El Conan
Goldberg,
who's also talked about hemispheric
function in the same way.
And so when things are going according
to plan,
let's say,
and then the individual ego
consciousness that's,
that's focused and specific stays in
charge,
but that also keeps negative emotions
regulate it because there's no need for
them because everything is working
properly.
And so then you can fall out of that and
you called that,
you called that exile?
No.
Uh,
when,
when you fall away from it.
Yeah.
When you fall away from the.
So that would be equivalent.
It's also the flood.
It's like.
Yeah,
fine.
Okay.
So I was like the wandering in the
desert.
Yeah,
it's the,
the idea of exile is,
it's exactly what we said.
It's about serving strange things so
you're not in charge anymore.
Fax something else is what you're in.
You're in that you live in a world where
you are not in charge or your identity
is not in charge of the facts and
they're not.
They don't fit with reality.
So that means something else is in
charge.
And so you're serving that.
So the idea of serving strangers in
exile,
it simply means,
oh,
that's really your identity doesn't
match reality.
Oh,
that's funny.
I never thought of it
both that,
that idea of serving strangers in exile.
So,
so.
Okay.
So I'm going to branch off that a couple
of different ways.
So one idea there is that there was an
idea from young,
which is paraphrased something like if
you don't,
if you don't act out your own myths and
you serve a bit part in the myths of
others,
okay,
so that would be in keeping with that
idea of serving the stranger in exile
and then the next part would be when
you're in a chaotic state and your
emotions are disregulated,
your personality fraction aids and the
fractionated personality personalities,
some personalities fight for control
over over over behavioral output so you,
you,
you dissolved from a unity might have.
Think about it as a pyramid,
a pyramid with with a unifying
conception at the top that
disintegrates.
That would be like the Tower of Babel to
some degree that disintegrates and then
sub entities,
you could think about them as spirits or
think about them as psychological
entities regulate your behavior.
That would be equivalent to a movement
from the left hemisphere to the right.
Because I think the right is dominated
by subcortical structures route.
I think that's how the animals exist,
is,
is it's sequential domination by
subcortical structures rather than some
overarching conceptualization from the
top down.
I think that,
um,
what you call it,
the left and the right is exactly the
opposite of the traditional left.
Right?
I'm not so sure yet,
but when you say left hemisphere,
what do you mean?
Well,
like what's the left hemisphere governs
the right hand.
Okay.
So the left hemisphere is the one that's
when it's.
When it's in charge and when everything
works.
Yes.
Okay.
It's exactly the opposite of the,
of the traditional imagery.
Usually the,
it's the right.
That's.
Well,
yeah,
because they're using the hands.
Yeah,
exactly.
So the right,
the right would be mapped onto the left
hemisphere.
Okay.
So that's fine.
That's fine.
Now.
And,
and the traditional imagery I think is
associated with the hemispheric
specialization as well because the idea
of right now I want to ask you a
question about that.
You said that they,
the,
the living,
what was it you contrasted exile with?
What was the other conceptualization
inhabiting the homeland inhabit?
Inhabiting the homeland?
Sure,
absolutely.
Working on working on the homeland is
another way to say,
okay,
now tell me again how you conceptualize
the relationship between God and and his
people.
Let's say in the homeland.
Uh,
well,
God,
like I said at the beginning,
there's the idea of heaven and earth is
that the basis and everything in the
Bible.
So heaven is meaning and earth is fact.
So in that relationship,
there's God,
it's always the name of God.
By the way,
if you look,
if you look in the way it's described in
the Bible,
it's,
they're talking about the name of God.
So that means the meaning of God.
So God is not just meaning,
but when they talk about it in the
Bible,
it's always about the name of God.
So the name of God is an identity.
It's like a principal in axiom or
something like that.
And um,
it has to embody itself in a physical
reality,
flesh or in matter.
So the,
the role of the nation of Israel is to
embody that identity.
And it's also to embody it in reality,
not just in themselves.
So basically there are a mediator
between heaven and earth,
right?
They're trying to make God's identity,
um,
practical or concrete or that's why it's
all about laws because you take a nap,
it's like mathematics.
You've taken that an abstract principle
that's really extremely simple.
Uh,
it doesn't seem like it.
It contains much information,
right?
If you take an axiom in mathematics,
but then you have to derive all the
implications,
right?
So that's making it practical,
that's making it concrete,
that's bringing heaven into the earth.
So that's their job.
It's like a cosmic mediator.
Okay,
okay.
Follow you so far.
So,
all right,
so the,
the,
it looks like there's two ways maybe in
the biblical narrative that that will,
is instantiated in,
in reality,
and one would be as a consequence of
individuals aligning themselves with the
word of God and the other is the
instantiation of the word of God into
the state of Israel seem seem
reasonable.
Okay?
And that seems to begin that that has
its origin in the,
in the first abrahamic story.
So Abraham talks to God and God talks to
Abraham and tells him that he's going to
be the father of the nation essentially,
and then
you'd like to inherit the land to order.
It's the same thing actually.
Those two things have the same is going
to inherit the land and he's going to
become the principal of a great many
people.
So that's like he's fleshing out an
identity,
right?
It gives a nation instead of just
individual.
Right?
And he's going to become the identity of
a nation.
Okay.
And so how do you understand the
description of that in the,
in the biblical narrative?
Because one of the very.
One of the things I find very strange
about abrahamic stories is that
immediate presence of God and God shows
up to Abraham and tells them this.
And then Abraham makes an altar,
if I remember correctly,
once he gets to the land where he's
supposed to be,
he makes an altar and then.
And then God appears to him again.
Yeah,
I'm not again,
not again,
appears to him the first time.
It doesn't appear.
I think I'm pretty sure the first time
God speaks to him.
Okay.
See that's,
that's important.
Okay.
The second time
distinction important.
Well,
because he's just,
he's just,
he's not physical.
He's not a into practical reality yet.
It's invisible.
So God speaks is he's not manifest.
It's just an idea principal at word.
Okay.
And unmanifest word or it's like the
minimum of manifestation.
It's just language,
just word.
And then.
So what he says is go to this place,
go to this land and you'll inherit the
lead.
And then he goes there and then it says
God appeared to him.
I see.
So,
okay.
So there's a,
there's a progression.
Progressive Progressive Appearance of
God and it's partly a consequence of
Abraham's original,
um,
obedience to the initial idea.
Yeah.
Which was very abstract.
Me Go here.
You can be more simple than that.
Go there.
So it's,
it's like,
it doesn't mean anything,
but it means everything.
It's a very.
Everything we do is I go there,
go there and do something.
So it's like the principle of all things
appeared to Abraham saying,
just go there and you'll inherit.
That doesn't really mean anything if it
contains everything humans do.
Yup.
Okay.
That's an interesting observation
because I think of human beings as other
very directional.
They're always going from point a to
point b.
they're always aiming there like
archers.
Right.
And it's definitely the case.
Like I had someone write to me.
No,
I was doing a Patriot interview with one
of the people who's been supporting me,
a young guy and uh,
we were talking about the idea of Christ
as redeemer and judge and he was,
this young man was unredeemed,
let's say for a long period of time
because he didn't have any direction.
And to have direction you have to know
what's good and what isn't.
Because to have direction you have to go
towards what's good.
And so the judge is what helps you
figure out what's good and if you don't
know what's good then you can't be
redeemed.
Because to be redeemed as to be is to be
moving towards the good and away from
let's say evil.
And so the judge and the redeemer have
to be the same thing.
And that fits in with what you're saying
because the judge is the thing that
makes qualitative distinctions,
let's say,
and you need to make a qualitative
distinction before you can move ahead.
Okay.
And so your point is that the principal
that Abraham encounters to begin with is
the principle of directionality itself,
qualitative directionality.
It's something like that.
That's correct.
Yeah.
It's.
Well,
it's,
it's the positive identity of anything.
Like it's,
it's like a seed.
It's the seed of a tree.
That's the traditional way to understand
it.
It's just a seed.
It contains everything in it,
but in itself it's just something like
go there or something go there.
Okay.
That's it.
So one of the things that's been
interesting,
I think for me to learn personally as
I've moved through my life was that if I
ever actually did anything,
it was worthwhile.
You know what I mean?
Is that something would come of it.
It wouldn't necessarily be what I expect
it to come of it,
but the act of going and doing did bear
fruit.
Yeah.
And that's pretty much the story of
Abraham in a nutshell.
Actually what you just said,
because God says,
go here,
you only inherited the land.
Abraham doesn't inherit the land.
He could have been right away.
It could have gone there and it's yours,
but no theirs.
That's why it says as soon as he gets
there and says there's already people
there,
there's the land is already owned by
other.
There's a famine.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and that means,
it means,
like what I was saying before,
the facts support the theory.
Okay,
and here is going to the land.
That's the theory you will inherit.
That's the theory.
And the facts don't support it.
That's a fun.
Okay.
The earth doesn't support you.
The earth doesn't give you sustenance to
make it reality.
It doesn't give you matter.
Yeah.
It gives you at that in Egypt,
and I mean his wife is separate
essentially because he lies about her.
But then it's so strange because.
So he tells the federal and the Pharaohs
man that his wife is actually a sister.
That's Sarah.
Sarah,
is that how you say that changes?
The name is actually his sister and
that's to protect them and so the
Pharaoh takes sariah and then it can
isolate something.
You bet there is
meaning to all of those things.
There's a meaning to it.
Okay,
so the idea is that when facts,
facts,
support the theory,
okay?
When,
when the flesh supports the identity or
the matters,
heaven.
Earth supports having things are square.
Okay?
That's just the traditional way of
understanding.
That basically means that what you see
is what you get.
Okay?
It's,
it's truth.
Things are true.
That's the definition of meaning matches
fact.
It's true when pragmatic definition.
Yeah.
When,
when the other side happens,
then things are around there.
They're cyclical.
Okay.
And it's.
It's.
It's essentially,
it's time.
It's space and time.
That's what it is.
Okay?
One of them.
You're falling into time.
Things are not square.
That means things do not.
The meaning doesn't mask the fact.
That's why it's all lies.
Okay?
When they go into exile,
it's all about lies and it's all about
dreaming,
okay?
Because they are in that domain.
They're in a domain where meaning in
fact doesn't match.
So everything happens through lies and
deception and even the whole idea of
saying,
my wife is my sister,
but that represents a cyclical paradox
that's supposed to happen.
Well,
why cyclical?
Um,
you're a parent has a son and a daughter
and they get married.
It's like a regression.
Okay?
It's like you're,
you're producing different things and
then you're joining them back together
and that's supposed to join back
together because when you joined them
back together,
it's like you're going,
you're regressing.
When you,
when you build something,
you start from principal and you develop
it.
Okay?
You make specializations.
That principle,
when you start to mix them up again,
it's like a regression.
You're,
you're going back to something more
primitive than before.
How do you see that in relationship to
Abraham's insistence that surgery,
his,
his sister.
Sister.
Yeah.
Because you're not supposed to marry
your sister.
And I'm not saying that as a moralistic
thing even though it becomes one,
but the reason you shouldn't marry your
sister is because you're undoing the
work.
The specializations is that your,
your,
your father or your mother Ha have
created.
It's like going back,
it's like regressing,
so like if you married your father or
your mother or depending,
you're going back,
it's a cycle.
You're not speaking to that because it's
like your annihilating something that
was specified.
Hey look,
I'll give you an example of like an
imagery of that that's pretty important
in,
in the story of the flood,
there are traditions that the giants
created.
Hybrids.
Okay.
Yep.
One of the things that giants like to do
is create hybrids.
They are hybrids themselves,
but they created hybrids.
They took the species and they confuse
them back into who knows what.
Okay,
and that's very significant because it
actually means that you are regressing
in it confused manner.
Okay.
That there's a connection between the
flood and what I just said,
making hybrids and causing the flood.
It's actually considered one in the same
thing.
Does that make sense?
It makes some sense.
Yeah.
It's about returning to confusion.
Yep.
Look,
I'll say it this way.
Adam named the animals had an adam named
the animals.
God asked Adam to names and it.
It's his first job in the universe,
so he's asking him to specify different
things that are all,
all have the same source,
the same as you differentiate.
That's the idea of incarnating a
principle into practice yet
differentiated.
Okay?
Now,
if you reverse that process,
you're going back to a more primitive
level.
You're going back to the flood because
the flood is the most primitive thing
in,
in that cosmology,
right?
It starts with a flooded world.
That means everything's in confusion.
So what'd you have to do is specify
things out,
but if you go back,
does that make sense?
So let,
let me,
let me reformulate that and tell you
what popped into mind.
Alright?
So God gives Abraham the word and then
Abraham follows it and God manifests
himself more completely to Abraham.
And then what happens?
Abraham is twofold.
He ends up in a barren land,
so nature rebels,
and he also ends up in a tyranny,
right?
Because he is not only,
not only does the land not produced,
so it's in a famine,
but Egypt eventually.
Egypt is generally speaking,
assemble for for tyranny throughout the
initial parts of the Old Testament.
I mean you see that with the Pharaoh,
for example,
and the symbolism in the mosaic story
of,
of the,
of Egypt always being associated with
stone instead of water,
and so you could say that God gives
Abraham the command to move forward,
but he has to contend with the
intransigent sea of nature which rejects
him because there was a famine and then
he becomes subjugate some.
It becomes subject to both tyranny and
deceit,
and so,
okay,
c,
two,
any are a look.
Okay,
I'll say it this way.
It's more about the tyranny,
okay?
But the thing is,
when you're not in charge,
I mean there's a tyranny.
That's it.
When you're you or whoever you identify
with is not in charge,
you're a slave to some other principle,
right?
You're embodying some other wheel that's
not you.
I mean,
that's tyranny,
right?
So,
right.
In that sense,
it's really directly relate to the idea
of tyranny.
You serving strangers,
right?
It says it all.
So motivates.
That also motivates Abraham's deception,
right?
Because he's terrified that the
strangers that he's serving will kill
him.
Yeah.
For his wife,
for his wife,
and that's why he likes it.
He's afraid that he's going to be
treated very badly.
Yeah.
Because he doesn't want strangers to
have his wife.
His wife is like the earth.
His wife is how he will incarnate,
can self or express itself in the world.
He's like the seed and the wife is like
the,
the earth,
something like that.
So she's the.
She is like his earth.
It's like a major version of heaven and
earth.
The male is,
is,
is the heaven and the female is the
earth.
In that case,
that's the whole idea.
He's not in charge of facts anymore.
That includes his wife,
that ingredients.
So he doesn't want other men,
other principals to control his wife.
Right.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
Well,
it also,
it also seems to me that because he's,
the land isn't fruitful for him and
because he's serving strangers in a
strange land,
he's also correct to be afraid for the
loss of his wife.
Yeah.
And how does he get out of it?
By being deceitful,
because he's in the cycle is in that.
I mean are you supposed to be truthful?
Your adversary usually know,
especially when your editor series
hostile and if you're an enemy
territory,
your morality changes because all of a
sudden it's not about being truthful,
it's about surviving.
It's about.
It's like the most primitive existence
there is.
The more primitive states of existence
are more about the seat than about
truth.
It's an advance.
It's an advanced state to talk about
truth.
It's when we all agree,
we all agree on at least something,
but before that it's every man or woman
for him or herself.
It's all about the seat.
It's all about survival.
Okay?
Okay,
so now.
Now the next thing that happens
essentially is that the pharaoh gets
played and he's wondering why.
So because.
So the story indicates that the Pharaoh
has broken some natural law,
let's say,
or some divine law and things go very
badly for him.
And then he discovers,
I don't remember how he discovers that
he's taken.
I think it,
it doesn't say how it's right.
And,
and he discovers that he's taken Sarah,
but Sarah is Abraham's wife.
And so then the pharaoh gives Abraham
all sorts of goods and sends him on his
way.
Okay.
So that's also quite confusing.
So Abraham is rewarded for his decision.
Ill ill gotten goods.
Yeah.
Right.
It'll go.
Good.
That's part of her story is interesting
because you also see,
I think in not account,
some of the complexity that's embedded
in the old testament accounts is that
it's not a simple morality tale.
It by any stretch of the imagination.
You especially see that in the Abrahamic
accounts because it's Jacob who who so
deceitful with Esol.
I mean,
Nissan comes off.
I mean he's,
he's gone.
He's gone out unconscious.
Esau.
Yeah.
He gives things up too easily.
He's too easily deceived and he's a bit
primitive.
I guess he's a bit too primitive in a
bit too naive,
something like that.
But Jacob plays and Rachel place some
really nasty tricks on him and yet they
come out ahead.
Yeah.
And so that's also a very difficult
thing to contend with.
Well,
there's,
there's this idea,
at least in,
in,
in traditional interpretation,
there's this idea that in Esol is
actually supposed to be that the key it
should be the only reason he isn't is
because there's something wrong.
That's pretty much describe the whole
Bible in its entirety.
The there's,
there's the theory and the fact the fact
is supposed to be king.
Okay.
Do you know what I mean by that?
Like at matter is king it,
that's what it's supposed to be,
but it's not.
And the whole,
all the stories are about redeeming.
Redeeming that problem,
taking care of that problem.
It's like the facts don't match the
theory.
We have to redeem the facts.
That's,
that's pretty much all the stories in
the Bible are about that and that's
pretty much what lock represents in the
story of Abraham as well.
Okay.
You represents a material reality.
He represents facts,
but there's something wrong with it.
Let's go into the large story now.
So.
Okay,
so Abraham leaves and I believe he
leaves with lot and,
and lot also becomes quite wealthy and
they go back to where Abraham had built
the altar initially,
but lot large men and Abraham's men
start to fight so they decide they're
going to separate and they basically do
that somewhat arbitrarily could,
could have gone either way,
but a lot ends up going to sort them.
Well actually there is something you
should be aware of.
Well that's the thing.
A lot of the stories in the Bible are
based on a really ancient way of
thinking that we don't really following
you more.
But I mean in the Bible there is a
reason why,
um,
the directions of the travels that
they're not just random,
like Egypt represents the earth.
And um,
what's the name of the city?
What's the name of the place of both her
and I think the place where he goes to
meet.
I'm leaving.
Uh,
it's in the north.
Okay.
I,
I'm not,
I'm not sure I remember the name of
this.
See,
I think it's Iran that represents
heaven.
Okay.
And there's a reason.
It's not just arbitrary,
it's because Egypt is south and south is
going down.
Right.
We still say that when,
when,
when you say that someone's gone south,
we say that means that they've gone to
seed or they've gone down.
Yeah.
So,
so in the Bible,
and especially in Genesis,
especially in finances,
um,
the south represents the earth and the
north represents that happens.
Okay.
And like I said,
it's not arbitrary it,
it corresponds to the geography of the
region.
One of them goes uphill and the other
one goes downhill.
And the north there's mountains,
snowy mountains.
In the south there's a Egypt which is
like the low,
a low place and yeah.
Right.
So north literally is up.
Yeah.
It's not a metaphor.
Literally is close going,
getting closer to heaven and the other
one going into the earth.
So when they go and excited to Egypt
there,
it's actually means they're going into
the earth.
It's like a descent into the earth.
So it's like death.
It's death and they say it a few times
in the book of Genesis it talk about
your,
it's like dying.
Going it,
going to Egypt is like a death.
Okay,
so then now.
So then we moved to the story of the
strangers.
Right.
Weight,
not who you were going to say,
why the separation of the land with lot
and uh,
and Abraham.
Yes.
Right.
The idea is that lot takes the,
the,
the south,
right.
And then Abraham.
Yeah.
That was the whole point of that.
Yeah,
a lot as a reason why he takes the
south.
It's the lowest place on Earth Sodom and
Gomorrah that,
that place.
It's the lowest place.
Okay.
So literally the lowest place on earth,
right?
I'm not sure about.
I know.
I don't know.
I think that region actually is the
lowest place on earth,
but in the story that that's how,
that's what it means.
It means it's the lowest plates.
So it's a place that's farthest away
from heaven.
Yeah,
it's the,
it's the idea that Milton develops with
regards to Satan when he's thrown from
heaven because the hell that Satan
inhabits is the furthest possible away
from heaven.
That's how it's defined essentially.
Yeah.
It's like a journey into the earth.
It's,
it's the same as,
um,
it needs the same thing as,
as falling asleep,
exiled and sleep are the same in the
Bible.
Sleep is,
is a form of exile.
Exactly.
So,
so the next thing that happens is that
we get the first warning about Sodom and
Gomorrah.
Yep.
That's just a very brief sentence.
It's like a foreshadowing.
And then the next thing that happens is
that there's an episode where there is a
war among kings and the kings,
if I remember correctly,
it's the King of Sodom takes a lot and
Abraham has to go rescue him.
Actually,
I think it's the other way around.
I think it's things from the north.
They come down and uh,
take Sodom and Gomorrah and lot is part
of that.
And so is the king.
The King of Sodom and Gomorrah.
They have to flee.
That's what I remember.
Do they flee with,
do they flee with lot?
No.
Law is taken by these chains from the
north and I'm the King of Sodom.
I think hides or something like that.
Fleece
the king,
the King of Sodom at the end gives gifts
to Abraham to thank him that he rescued.
Yes,
that's right.
So what happens is that,
yeah,
it says in and it came to pass in the
days of Amarillo,
Elle,
king of Shinar,
et Cetera,
that these made war with Barbara,
King of Sodom and with Burger King of
Gomorrah,
et Cetera,
and these were all joined together in
the veil of cinnamon,
which is in the old seat,
which is the salt seat,
so I presume that would be the Dead Sea
and that would be the low point that
you're describing is the dead seat.
That's pretty interesting.
And the veil of cinema was full of slime
pits and the kings of Sodom and Gomorrah
fled and fell there,
and they took away all the goods of
Sodom and Gomorrah and older victuals,
and they took lot Abram's brother's son
who dealt in,
dwelt in Sodom and his goods and
departed.
So
you can really see this whole geography
that matthew is talking about.
When they say that Sodom and Gomorrah,
they had to flee and fall into pits.
It's almost like they're laying it out
for us that they had to almost kind of
go even further down into the earth,
the hide from these,
these,
uh,
these invaders of the north that are
coming to take their land.
So.
Okay.
So Abraham goes and rescues lot and he
does not successfully.
And the Ndaa also,
there's,
there's kings,
but he.
Did he freeze as far as I can tell?
Yeah,
probably.
Then the kings wanted to reward him and
Abraham says to the King of Sodom and he
doesn't want any reward.
And the reason he doesn't want any
reward except for what is men have
equal.
He doesn't want any reward because I
will not take anything that is thein
lest thou should say I have made Abraham
rich save only that which the young men
have eaten and the portion of men which
went with me and it looks.
See God has already promised Abraham
everything in some sense.
And it looks like he doesn't want to
take anything at Abraham.
Doesn't want to take anything from
anyone else because what would it do?
Would it interfere with the purity of
his accomplishments?
Something like that.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I don't know for certain because,
um,
that's just a line I guess,
but in the,
in the story,
I mean,
it's not that much of a big part of the
story,
but the way I see it is I think he says,
I don't want to take even this shoe lash
to latch for me.
Okay.
So there's a reason why he says that
because the shoe is the lowest part is
the lowest clothing,
right?
It's on the feet.
So it's all related to the idea that the
earth needs to be redeemed.
Need,
needs to be rectified.
And it in that situation,
it's not like he's not allowed to accept
it.
It's the same thing is not eating the
forbidden fruit.
There are things in the world that are
poisonous to humans.
We can't eat them because they don't
agree with,
are our patterns,
our,
our mind.
So if you eat poison,
you go into that place where things
don't agree,
your mind and your body don't agree.
I mean,
if you,
if you take,
if you drink alcohol,
um,
that takes you into the where your mind
and your body don't agree.
The theory doesn't match the fact and
then you go into that whole confusion.
Yes.
Those,
could it be that when,
when,
um,
he doesn't,
he doesn't want to take from Sodom
because Sodom is already what we know
saw them to be.
I mean,
it already represents kind of the,
the land that can't hold and will be
burned off.
Yeah.
It's something he can,
he can integrate something.
It's like,
that's why I said the forbidden fruit.
You don't want to eat.
You don't want to accept mattered that
you can't handle,
that you can integrate.
So there's something in that place that
he doesn't know how to deal with,
what to do with it and he doesn't want
his riches to come from that place.
He doesn't write,
he doesn't want his riches to come from
that place because it would compromise
them
because he doesn't know how to deal with
it yet.
Maybe someday he will.
That's right.
That's the whole idea.
And actually,
here's an interpretation,
lot represents that place that will one
day be redeemed.
Okay?
The reason why they talk about lots so
much in the story of Abraham is because
he represents King David.
He is the ancestor of the nation that
will give rise to King David.
Okay?
It's like a secondary story within the
story,
but it's like a.
it's meant to be interpreted in terms of
a future redemption of that place that
he can handle,
that Abraham couldn't handle at that
time.
And that place will be redeemed.
I'm giving you a lot of tradition here,
but this is what I would.
I would,
I've learned.
It's King David.
Okay.
It's the future king.
So the whole story of luck is about King
David.
Well,
and of course Lord is Abraham's
descendants as well because he's his
nephew.
Yeah.
So Abraham's nephew descends into the
lowest place essentially.
Yeah.
Well,
look it,
the story that starts out pretty clear,
it starts out there's three sons to a
tear up.
One of them is harass.
The other one's not horror.
And the other one's Abraham.
Okay?
Heroin dies.
That's how the story starts.
That's like the beginning of this story
is Aaron dies and he has a son called
lot.
See,
that's what I was it.
The idea is it's the same idea.
The son of this heroin,
he represents death.
He represents the thing we can't handle.
You represents the material facts that
we can explain with the,
with our theories or with our identity
is the thing we is the matter.
We can't handle it.
And that's why in the story starts with
he dies the father of lot dice.
It a
lot represents some fact that we cannot
correctly,
okay
integrate into our universe.
This could be interpreted in so many
different levels.
But um,
that's basically what it is.
I don't know if that makes sense,
but the idea the.
I mean,
the idea is that I think we need to see
it.
The idea is that an orphan or a widow,
that's what they always represent.
They represent something that have lost
their,
their principle that unifies them.
They're here.
They're kind of disconnected from the
hierarchy of the family.
So,
so,
so a lot losing is the fact that losing
his father died me,
that he loses the thing that gives him
identity and so he's like this,
he's like a,
a,
a piece of birth that is lost attachment
or last meeting or.
Well,
that,
that reminds me of what happens to know
his son
who
sees him naked.
Yeah.
Right.
And,
and because,
because to see,
it seems to me,
I'm going to talk about this a little
bit tonight,
that to see noah gets drunk and then
which,
which son is that have pam ham.
Yeah.
I'm really first sees him but doesn't
respond properly.
The other sons,
when they see no one naked,
they cover him up and they don't look.
And so it's like they're not exposing
their fathers weakness.
His mortality is his,
his insufficiency,
right?
They didn't retain respect,
but ham doesn't do that.
But there's also more what matthew was
talking about before they're in that
story.
There's two things that are implied of
what matthew was talking about before,
this idea of wine that brings you into
this cycle where causality ceases to be
a direct.
And then what happened to the faction?
Yeah.
And the fact that he sees his father
naked,
he discovers his nakedness is also a
kind of suggestion of incest as well.
The same type,
the same type of,
of,
of inappropriate causality that you see
in the story of the two,
of,
uh,
of uh,
Abraham's sister marrying his sister,
luck with his two daughters,
two daughters.
Right?
So it's transgression.
It gets some funding.
Transgression against some fundamental
boundary.
Yeah.
Against the,
the hierarchical relationship.
And have a family,
right?
Yeah.
You're not supposed to make loops.
It's a tree.
You're not supposed to make loops in a
tree.
So you can say like that.
It's really simple and that's supposed
to regress and I supposed to.
You produce things,
you're not supposed to turn back on
yourself.
You're not supposed to go back.
So,
so maybe that's why lot's wife has
turned into a pillar of salt
because she lives back,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It has to do it.
Looking back to the mental
and,
uh,
and pines for something that it was
terrible.
It shouldn't have been.
And so,
and she's commanded not to look back
once you,
once you escape from that catastrophe,
you don't get to be nostalgic for it.
And the same thing happens in the story
of Moses because what happens to the
Israelites when they were out in the
desert is they start to become nostalgic
for Egypt,
for the tyranny.
Right.
And that's also,
I think when God starts to send
poisonous snakes among them,
because right though,
don't they,
they,
they start to pine for Egypt and
complain about Moses and then they start
to worship other idols.
So that's part of that confusion that
you were talking about.
And then God gets irritated and throws a
bunch of poisonous snakes in there to
give them a good chomping.
Yep.
So that's the snakes come as a result of
them wanting to go back.
Yeah.
Well,
right.
That makes perfect sense.
So,
and you see that nostalgia for tyranny.
You know,
you see that the Soviet Union in Russia
right now with regards to stolen.
And so the question,
the question is,
I think this is one of the things that
I'm the guy who wrote the disappearance
of God mentioned this.
Do you want to be well fed as a slave or
hungry and freedom,
something like that.
And the choice.
Well,
fed as a slave is not a good choice.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
now.
So when Jonathan,
you and I talked a fair bit about the
story of Abraham and the strangers
before.
So I'm.
So God decides to reward Abraham and he
tells him that just like he told him
before,
but he repeats it,
that he's going to be the founder of a
nation and he,
and he tells them that Sarah is going to
bear a child.
And Sarah of course is not.
Doesn't believe that.
Let's see.
Let me,
let me just find this here.
Yeah.
Yes.
Okay.
So that's what happens is,
is that God's God,
God's word comes into Abraham in a
vision.
So what's the word again?
Saying that his reward will be great and
that he's going to be the father of
nations,
but he doesn't have any children.
And so isn't that when he takes
you take Sarah's servant,
Hagar?
Yeah.
And,
and that gives rise to Ishmael.
And it wasn't until later that Sarah is
informed that she's sorry that he went
fancy your question.
She wants one.
Answer your question.
I'd be curious to know what she has
found you.
She closed her down.
Yeah,
I know.
It was pretty strange.
Intermission there.
So.
Okay.
So,
so Abraham has to take kind of a detour
in order to have a child and he lays
with Hagar and Hagar,
uh,
we don't know much about her,
but she gets he right away and starts to
despise Sarah.
And Sarah actually beats her as far as I
can tell.
It says Sarah delk hardly with her and
then Hagar fleets.
And she ends up by A.
Well,
we're an angel.
Appears to her.
And uh,
the angel tells her that her son,
her child is going to be the father of
the nation as well.
So,
so the first question might be,
why is it that Abraham,
at this point in the story,
why is it necessary for the story that
Abraham takes a detour and has a child
with Hagar?
What do you think that signifies?
It's,
it's,
it's always the same problem in the
Bible.
It's always,
it starts with confusion and it has to
develop towards something that is clear.
So you're saying that yourself,
when you say detour?
Yeah,
it's a detour.
Exactly.
That's exactly what it is.
It's a detour.
Great.
That's not necessary,
but it happens.
Does that make sense?
Well,
D two is teach.
Detours are the doors are things that
are not necessary,
but at the end
there's something also in that detour,
the fact that he gives birth to Ishmael,
which has to do with this,
this turning because God kind of
promises that Ishmael is going to come
back and he's going to be a big problem
for you.
He's going to be a father of a great
nation,
but he's going to be a big problem for
you later.
Like it's going to be.
There's going to be fighting between
between your sons basically.
Yeah.
There's that idea.
Yeah,
of course.
I don't know if it's in that story,
but
yeah.
Well,
it seems to be associated with an idea
that you might take about as success of
approximation to an ideal.
No.
So one of the things that that I've
conceptualized sort of visually is,
and this is associated with the idea of
Jupiter wishing on a star.
It was so what's your who does when he
wants to facilitate the transformation
of Nokia was lifted his eyes up to the
highest thing that he can conceive of
and Orient Yourself with that.
But the thing is is that as you move
through life,
let's say you're oriented by the highest
thing you can conceive of,
but as you move towards it,
you transform and then and your
conceptualization of what's the highest
shifts as you transform.
So you're aiming at the highest thing
but,
but your perhaps your ability to
conceptualize what's the highest thing
develops as you move towards it.
And so what that means in practice is
that you do take detours because you aim
at something,
but you're aim is off and you move
towards it and then you get to a point
where you can correct your aim.
And so it's not like you've made a
mistake.
Exactly.
It's,
you're farther ahead than you were and
you've corrected your aim,
but your aim wasn't.
You weren't aiming at exactly the right
thing to begin with.
Yeah.
And so
yeah,
go ahead.
Well,
maybe that's what's happening to Abraham
is that,
you know,
you could almost say,
I don't know if Ishmael is a practice
run,
something like that.
So.
All right,
so then you were going to,
you matthew,
you were to say something about that.
Oh yeah,
I was going to say that
exiled in the Bible.
Um,
there's always a reason for it,
but it's not necessarily a logical
reason.
It's,
it's,
it's just like what you described.
You think,
you know,
something,
you think you'd know what you're aiming
at.
You think you know what you want,
you think you know what you're doing.
Something happens that you didn't plan.
That doesn't look like it's part of what
you were aiming.
It makes you take a detour.
Well,
this,
this site is all about detours.
It's all about turning around.
You don't know where you're going.
You're lost.
So,
but in the end it,
it brings about something that maybe you
weren't even aiming at in the,
in the,
in the first place.
What might be better than what you were
in yet in the first place.
So it's not all bad.
So I think that's the idea.
The idea of the whole idea of exile is
that there it renews your plans,
right?
If you don't die,
yeah.
Even if you do die,
it renews your planning.
Okay,
so now.
Sure.
Now the next thing that happens is that
the strangers come to visit Abraham and
he treats them hospitably and so now we
might say that that's an indication of
his increasing alignment with the good.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about
it because he does right by the stranger
and one of the consequences of that is
that the angels,
I guess we find out that there are
angels.
Tell him that Sarah is going to give
birth to someone and Abraham finds that
very difficult to believe.
It's Sarah finds it so difficult to
believe that she actually laughs about
it.
She overhears it,
she laughs about it,
but,
but he,
he has the strangers,
he feeds them.
He has them wash their feet,
if I remember correctly.
And um,
anyways,
he treats them hospitably at well and
there's a blessing as a consequence of
that.
And that's something we talked about a
fair bit,
Jonathan when we were talking about the
things that doesn't fit in categories.
Yeah.
The Stranger.
Which is that invitation to chaos as
well that you were talking about
matthew,
because the stranger is while the thing
that you can be subjugated to,
but also something that will bring
something new and potentially disruptive
but also potentially beneficial.
And so then the idea there is whether or
not the stranger is disruptive or
beneficial depends to a large degree on
how you treat the stranger.
And that strikes me as very,
very possible.
I mean,
that's the one thing that that's one of
the things that has really entered my
imagination as a clinician.
Now,
if you're approached by someone who's
very in chaos,
the consequence of that is very
dependent on how you interact with them
because it can go any way and they're
not really in control because there are
so chaotic and so if you're careful and
awake,
you can keep things moving in the proper
direction and maybe even benefit from it
and that's Kinda like the idea of
walking with God because one of the
reasons that no one gets through the
flood is because he is oriented
properly.
He's walking with God and so you could
say that exile can.
It's something like exile can expand
you.
If you stay properly oriented while
you're in exile,
it could fit.
It can fix your mistakes.
That's part of it.
It cleans you.
It renews you because you make mistakes
and they become part of you and if
you're stuck with your mistakes,
you're rigid about your own estates.
You need something outer to something
that you don't know,
something that you don't understand to
clean your mistakes away.
Yeah.
Well that's like
the Golden Dragon Horse with the Virgin,
the Dragon Horts,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's the dragon represents that chaotic
would say Exxon state that drag the gold
and the and the virgin both represent
that which can be assimilated as a
consequence of being in that situation.
The funny thing is,
is in the hero myths going into exile on
purpose works way better than going into
exile accidentally.
So that's an interesting thing.
So.
Okay.
Okay,
so
can I say something about the part you
were describing that the whole story of
Abraham,
if you look at the big picture,
it's really about progressive,
a progressive Lee knowing something.
So it started with just the voice of
God.
Go here.
It doesn't mean much goes there.
Then it becomes a little more precise.
I will give you this land.
So now it's more specific,
and then as the further he goes,
the more it becomes explicit what's
going to.
So I'll give you a sudden when I don't
know,
someday it doesn't say later on it
becomes more and more explicit,
gay,
and he says like in the party we were
talking about,
he says,
three men come.
These are angels as,
as it becomes clear later.
So this is God,
right?
God sending his message in a clear
manner and it's more specific.
Then before he says,
this time next year you will have it.
Sound good.
So okay.
So a couple of things about that.
So one of the things that see,
one of the ways that I've conceptualized
the relationship between the Old
Testament and the new testament and I,
this is kind of a classic Christian
conceptualization,
I think.
And it's also,
it's also analogous to what happens to
Moses because Moses doesn't get to the
promised land.
So there's this idea,
Christian idea that the reason that
Moses can't get to the promised land is
because he only represents the law now.
But then I thought about that.
I thought,
well,
one of the,
I've got to say about four stories at
the same time here at him to get the
parallelism right.
So the first is,
it's not so easy to speak the truth,
but it's fairly easy to stop light and
so as you stop lying,
you get better.
You get to approximate speaking the
truth,
but the way you start isn't by speaking
the truth.
The way you start is by stopping light
and then a lot of the rules in the Old
Testament or prohibitions.
Here's a bunch of things you shouldn't
do that you might be inclined to do.
And so the idea there would be if you
stopped doing all the things you know
you shouldn't do,
then you can.
Your head clears up,
but now so you can start to see the
things that you should do.
And so then in the Abrahamic story,
maybe it's something like this,
you said you implied matthew,
that Abraham originally follow something
like a vague and ill defined whim,
but he has enough faith to move forward
despite the fact that it's vague and ill
defined.
And then as a consequence of moving
forward,
it becomes more and more concretized and
and differentiated and clear.
Okay,
that's right man,
because that's,
you know,
it's funny because the future authoring
program we've developed sort of
predicated on that idea.
The first thing you do is wander around
in a kind of confused days,
trying to find a direction of
orientation and then you clarify that.
And partly you do that by continuing to
think about it,
but you also clarified by acting on it.
Okay.
Yep.
And the idea that these three men that
come visit him,
um,
there's a reason why there's three.
Okay.
It's because it,
it's,
it's trying to express the idea that
it's more expressed,
it's more explicit.
It's not just the seed anymore,
it's like,
it's like a branch.
Okay,
you got it.
Okay.
You got something that looks like a
branch.
It's branching out into a more concrete
thing and at first it's just a voice.
Then it's a vision that it's actual
people.
Okay.
So here's another idea.
So let's say if you're beginning to
develop morality,
you,
you behave so that the people who share
your morality can get along with you.
That means you follow the rules,
but if you're dealing with strangers,
it's a different issue because they
aren't part of your morality and so the
question then is how do you act properly
when you're not in the domain of your
morality,
and I always thought about that as a
matter moral domain and it seems to me
that it's the domain that Christ
occupies because he's.
He's like the mediator between
morality's.
He's in no man's land and is the
mediator between moralities and if
you're.
If you're,
if you've oriented yourself properly,
then you even know how to act with.
There aren't any rules and that's why
Abraham can act properly in relationship
to the strangers.
He's awake enough so that when the
strangers show up,
shows up,
he can pay attention to the way they're
acting and could act spontaneously as a
consequence of paying attention and
things go well and so the strangers
aren't hostile.
They don't kill them,
they don't take his wife.
They don't do any of the terrible things
that strangers could do and he gets a
blessing as a consequence of it.
Does that seem reasonable?
It is,
but we have to understand that these
strangers
are
come from heaven in the sense that they
are bringing a message.
They're not just random strangers right
there sent,
but maybe he would have acted the same
way with a stranger that wasn't sent and
that's the whole point.
He doesn't know.
He acts in a way that allows for that.
For the one that sent it can be
received.
Okay,
so that's very interesting too because
one of the things that I think you see
happening as a consequence of the
transition from the Old Testament,
the new testament is that part of
Christ's message is to act in exactly
that way,
is to act in a manner that allows for
the possibility of the emergence of the
good.
That's something like that.
Something like what would you describe
it as a description of the necessity of
faith and you know like let's say you
stretch out your hand to someone in
trust.
You shouldn't be naive,
but it's a precondition for good things
happening.
Like if you're distrustful and you have
every reason to be because people are
full of snakes.
If you're distrustful,
you've,
you foreclose the opportunity for
cooperative progress instantly,
you might protect yourself against being
bitten now in that so,
so there is a dramatic relationship
between the manner in which you open
yourself up to the world and the way the
world treats you,
and one of the things that seems to be
really emphasized,
it's more implicit in the Old Testament,
more explicit.
The New Testament is that the more you
open yourself up to the possibility that
good things will happen and that's
partly by accepting your vulnerability.
As far as I can tell,
the higher the probability is that good
things will in fact happen.
Alright.
Yeah,
I mean I would definitely say that in
the story of Abraham,
the like we were kind of flirting around
that idea before,
is that the reason why he was able to
receive them as these angel,
that they were able to manifest
themselves as these angels was because
he was willing to host them properly.
He,
he like,
it's as if he had his family just like
Sarah,
like Sarah is his,
is he was the right ground for that
manifestation at that time.
Right,
well you say that they wouldn't have
been angels if he wouldn't have treated
them properly.
Well,
it might've been.
It might've done.
They might have done what they did in
Sodom and Gomorrah.
That's the whole point.
Okay,
so now I want to switch.
I want to flip ahead.
This is really what this is.
I think of all the things I wanted to
discuss with you guys,
I think this is the one that's most
crucial because.
Okay,
so now we're in,
let's say we're in of with the,
with the angels and we're,
we're in the part of the story where the
townspeople of Sodom gather around the
house and they tell lot and unless he
throws out the strangers so that they
can be raped.
Well,
the,
this,
the townspeople demand that and then um,
lot offers them his daughters,
which seems like a hell of a thing to
do.
It's like the sacrifice of Isaac to some
degree.
That's what it looks like to me because
he's willing to sacrifice his daughters
to protect the strangers now.
Okay,
so that's morally,
let's call that a morally ambiguous
element of the story,
but then the townspeople reject that and
they,
they tell,
they basically tell him that he has no
right or power to bargain and that not
only are they going to take his
daughters,
but they're also going to take the
strangers so it doesn't work,
but you know,
to a,
to modern sensibility,
the offering of his daughters is a
reprehensible thing,
but it seems to be it in the context of
the story.
It's an indication of how hard lot is
trying to treat the strangers properly
in a place where that's essentially
impossible.
Yeah.
That's the whole point of that story.
That place is impossible.
That's the whole point.
I think what he just said,
okay.
There's no way out of it.
Right.
Leonard Cohen said something about that.
He said there's.
You had a line that I remember quite
well.
You said there's no decent place to
stand in the massacre and what that
seems to mean is that something.
It's something like you can get into a
place where it's made of such a compound
of errors and deceit and catastrophe
that no matter which way you turn,
there is no good.
No,
I've seen people like that in my
clinical practice.
There's,
there's no good,
there's no good alternative.
Everything is sin.
That's.
That's a good way of,
no matter which way you shoot your,
you're not going to hit the mark because
you're not somewhere where the market
can be hit.
Okay.
Now I've been trying to think about the
story of Sodom and Gomorrah in
relationship to modern sexual confusion,
so this is what I see happening on the
social justice front,
let's say on the one hand since the 19
sixties and probably as a consequence of
the birth control pill,
but other factors as well.
There's been tremendous stress placed on
sexual liberation and so there's this
idea that I think is associated in large
part right now with the radical left of
total sexual freedom,
but at the same time there's increasing
emphasis from exactly the same sources
on restricting sexual interactions.
So you see this in the campuses,
for example,
where increasingly particularly
heterosexual contact is regulated by a
doctrine that says you have to get
spoken permission for every move in the
mating process and so you see,
and I know I'm not expressing myself
very well,
but there seems to be in our current
culture there seems to be massive sexual
confusion.
It's,
it's some weird combination of extreme
libertarianism and extreme authoritarian
attitudes towards sexuality and and
obviously in the story of Sodom,
part of what's happening happening and
is that sex impulsive?
Sexual gratification trumps everything.
It's something like that.
I mean I know there's more to what's
going on inside them than that,
but there's certainly that and so.
Well,
I'm trying to figure out what to say
about that tonight because there's a.
there's a lesson in there.
The lesson is something like,
don't let sexuality,
don't let impulsive sexuality get the
upper hand.
It's something like that or all hell
will break loose.
Which I actually happen to agree with
because one of the things that we
haven't been able to talk about in our
culture I think is.
Let's take the idea of the phenomena of
aids aids mutated to take advantage of
promiscuous sexuality and that's just
nothing you never hear that publicized.
You know,
people had associated aids with
homosexuality and there was a reason for
that because it's much more easily
transmitted as a consequence of
homosexual sex than heterosexual sex
because the anus is a much more delicate
physiological structure.
It's not as robust and it can be much
more easily damaged and and and with
with disease resulting as a consequence,
but it isn't only the manner of sexual
action,
that's the issue.
It's also the fact that promiscuity
provided the evolutionary platform for
the AIDS virus to mutate into a very,
into the form that it took and it was
only through the school,
by the skin of our teeth that we escaped
a totalizing plague.
No had that emerged a hundred years ago,
God only knows how many people would
have died.
It AIDS was unbelievably fatal.
So I know that's a mishmash of ideas and
I'm not exactly sure how to see my way
clear through it,
but there is a clear warning in that
story about about something about
something to do with,
with,
with sexual inequity,
but in the Bible that sexuality has to
two Poles that define it and it's pretty
clear.
One,
one side is reproduction and the other
side is with let's say recreation.
Okay.
So those are the two bowls of sexuality
in a normal work.
So it's not just for reproduction and
it's not just for recreation.
It's both.
Right.
That was the idea.
I mean it's a natural idea.
Now if you.
If there's a balance there that should
be had.
If you lose this balance and it becomes
just about reproduction,
that's a problem.
And if it becomes just about recreation,
that's another problem.
Yup.
Okay.
It's not that complicated really,
but it's so politically incorrect to
talk about these things even though
they're obvious,
nobody dares to talk about it.
The thing is is that the most difficult
things to talk about are the things that
are obvious because when they're obvious
you don't have to talk about them and so
then when people start to question the
obvious,
you don't know what to say.
Yeah.
It's like,
so for example,
we would.
I'm thinking about the slut walks,
you know,
and so women go out and they dress very
provocatively and they go out and
manifest their right to be as
provocative as they possibly can be
without being interfered with.
And I have some sympathy for that
perspective because it seems to me
appropriate for women to be.
The final arbiter is in sexual contact,
but on the other hand,
it also,
it's that whole exercise is blind to the
fact that clothing,
for example,
has communicative intent
and that
people broadcast their invitation to
sexual congress in a million ways.
Subtle and not so subtle.
And you can't just say,
I have the right to broadcast myself in
any manner possible and be completely,
um,
can,
can be worked completely immune from the
consequences.
There's something wrong with that.
And with regards to basic sexual
morality,
no,
I've read things about like slut shaming
is that the more radical feminist types,
for example,
claim that women shouldn't be held
responsible for their sexual behavior in
some sense it shouldn't be held against
them,
how many men they've slept with,
etc.
But then I think,
well,
you'd never recommend to someone that
they laid down naked on the,
on the side of the street with their
legs spread and invite anybody who walks
by to partake of the opportunity.
Everyone would regard that as
inappropriate,
I think without question.
And so what that indicates is that some
degree of sexual propriety is Both
normative and ethical.
And then of course you can start asking
yourself about what that degree of
social sexual impropriety should be.
And It does have something to do with
getting the balance between reproduction
and recreation.
Right?
Okay.
Well,
the,
the thing,
even in the bible,
there's the two aspects.
Some stories are about just this aspect
in,
there are the most strange stories in
the bible.
For example,
the story of I'm tamar is one of those.
So,
uh,
I don't know if you're familiar with
that story,
but it's tough.
It's in the,
it's,
it's intercut with the story of joseph
in Egypt and it's essentially a,
it says that judah had children with
some woman and I think it's a stranger.
It doesn't necessarily say so,
but it seems like that's what it is.
And then the sons die off.
And then there's this woman called tamar
and she disguises herself as a
prostitute.
Great.
And she has a kid with judah himself.
So all of the symbols are in that story.
Elements of his clothing.
Yeah.
Demonstrate as a,
as a bride.
Yeah.
Essentially
wants to indicate later that he's the
one who slept with.
Yeah.
So that story is about the necessity,
the need for the recreative part of
sexuality.
It's all about that symbolism.
It's all about the seat.
It's all about incest.
It's all about death.
And it's.
The idea is it's to raise the dead.
Okay.
It's not clear in the story,
but if you understand,
if you understand the imagery,
that's what it's about.
It's about regressing back to an error
that was made.
Okay.
And raising the dead so,
and I don't want to get into it,
but it's just the idea that in the bible
there's both to the hearse reproduction
and there's recreation and the
recreation is renewal.
There's the renewal sexuality's about
renewal too.
But that aspect of the symbolism is,
is pretty.
I don't want to say obscure because it's
actually right there if you can see it,
but it's strange.
I'll say it like that.
It's a strange.
Okay.
So now another element of this might be
the fact that in modern identity
politics,
sexual choice is a canonical identifier.
And that also seems to me to be
something wrong about that.
Like one of the things I've seen
happening in toronto,
I'm sure it's the same in montreal,
is that,
and I'm going to do this awkwardly.
I'm going to put this awkwardly because
I haven't been able to sort through it
properly.
Um,
pride week.
Pride day has turned into pride week and
that's turned into pride month.
And I think that seems to me to be
pushing against some kind of limit.
Because the first question that I have
is like I was reading this book the
other day by a friend of mine from
ottawa who's a gay conservative and he
said he had a lot harder time coming out
as a conservative than he had as coming
out as gay and he talked about the
degree to which homosexuals were
persecuted in Canada before say the 19
eighties and it's quite.
It makes quite a harsh reading,
let's say,
and so and so fair enough to the,
to the civil rights movement,
let's say it,
that that has brought homosexuality into
the norm or that into the mainstream.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about
it,
but that conversation still has a
tremendous amount of development.
It's necessary because I don't
understand exactly.
It isn't obvious to me what integration
into the mainstream precisely means
because a lot.
There's been a lot of talk so far about
respecting the rights of gay people,
but very little talk about what the
accompanying responsibilities might be.
That actually it seems to me to be a
problem and I mean I.
I just had a letter from,
from guy gay guy who has been wrestling
with this because he's not sure how to
be gay and to be ethical at the same
time,
you know,
because he sees part of normative
behavior is taking wife and having
children and not and can see the value
in that,
but that's certainly not the direction
of his proclivity.
And so we wrote,
wrote to me asking me what he should do
and you know,
I don't have an answer for that.
I don't know what the answer to that is,
but I know that it might be something
that would be worth talking about and
it's part of this current confusion
about sexual identity and sexual
pleasure and,
and we'll even gender identity for that
matter.
So.
All right,
so your idea was,
well the balance between recreation and
reproduction had gone,
was completely absent inside them.
It was all recreation.
It was all instant gratification and
impulse.
Yeah.
And that's why it's put in the contrast
with the abraham bit because it's the
same angels.
But in that case he says,
you'll have a son this time next year.
So it's the reproduction part is there,
but when he gets to the
bottom,
it's not there anymore.
It's only the recreation part.
Okay.
So they're,
they're,
they're meant to be contested.
Those two stores actually in the story
of abraham,
it's pretty clear.
He goes,
um,
I don't know if this will make sense
because when the angels come it says,
um,
he washes their feet and then he feeds
them.
Okay.
That's actually the recreation and
reproduction part that not in terms of
sexuality,
but it's in terms of meaning the
renewal,
the washing of the feet is the
recreation part,
their renewal,
they're restarting and the feeding is
the reproduction part,
not in a sexual way,
but when you feed something food and he
eats it,
it integrates,
it integrates it correctly.
That's like our reproduction of your
identity,
your,
you're staying yourself,
you're reproducing yourself.
So when you eat food,
that's what you're doing.
Not,
like I said,
not in a sexual way,
but it has exactly the same.
Meaning if you eat something that you
can integrate correctly,
you're like reproducing your pattern is
the correct version of yourself.
The other side,
the washing is that like is that little
flood
the fuck so many flood,
right?
It's an acceptable.
It's a controlled one.
You're washing the dust off your.
The roads dust off your feet.
It means that you're.
You're passing from one mode of being
into another because you're.
You're cleaning off the debris of the
past.
It's something like that and that it's
about renewal next year,
so you have to see that when,
when,
when matthew was talking about,
yeah,
you have recreation,
you have to understand that recreation
and rest are basically the same thing.
ThEn you basically have the same
meaning.
It's sleeping,
resting,
recreation are all that bring you into
renewal.
okay,
bye.
And dying.
Dying.
Dying is.
It's passing into another state,
letting something else have a chance
that's quit tying his.
I.